all right so our next episode the earth
King see I can say that title um if boy
it wasn't this a nollie was this a
fascinating one in terms of just how
much can be hidden from a politician at
the top which again I don't find super
shocking um it's especially not prison
in charge um but a figure I should say
you know how much is kept away from a
figurehead because honestly when you
think about how much a person who is
supposed to know everything is supposed
to know there's no way anyone can get
all this information so a lot of times
they have to just act like they know
what they're talking about or smile or
Lane put this way they could know all
this stuff if they gave up everything
resembling a social life you know and
anything that would keep them sane so
it's understood but at the same time
this is like the other extreme this is
just knowing nothing and this King being
very naive but also very sort of hopeful
and sort of wants to listen and is nice
enough to not just totally disregard
everything and everyone ah so you got
the kids break-in through this again
mayonese action scene these action
scenes for me how good they are um and
this is just breaking into the palace
trying to talk to the king this isn't
even like one of the big massive ones I
mean that if anything they're
apologizing when they get the people
saying so we just got seen the king but
it's unbelievable this animation I
cannot get over how consistently good
the animation is and the planning of the
action and the choreography all of it
just spectacular again just unbelievable
to the animation team um so they break
in they see this King the they they're
told if they're not enemies drop their
weapons they drop their weapons and they
get arrested which is great um but the
King still says let me listen to what
they have to say improve it
I love that they make it very clear that
ank and they have sort of these weird
and rock cuff they're literally hands
they're cuffing them um and they show
very clearly that n can get out and
whenever you watch but he'll still abide
you know so I like that I like whenever
it shows look I could kill you right now
but I'm here I'm trying to show more and
more than I'm your friend
so they go through they bring the king
to the outer wall and they show that the
drill was there from that one battle and
that finally convinces him that a lot of
stuff is kept from him and that they're
at war he doesn't even know they're at
war so the King agrees that he will do
what he can for this war he knows how
important it is and the guy who was
second in command or whatever he's now
put in jail and he seems to be out of
commission but then of course men the
Sokka and Aang they have to do the kiss
of death they gotta say I think
everything's gonna be all right and you
know everything's not gonna be all right
when somebody says everything's gonna be
all right
so before Sokka says that we get this
news that uh sue K and two of her
friends are have arrived at the earth
Kingdom well just at the point when
everyone's about to split up and go
their way and you know immediately
especially when Sokka says well yeah
it'll be great to see him when I get
back
why don't you see him before you go
obviously so they can build up that
that's azulon or two friends as soon as
I heard three was the Kyoshi warriors or
whatever at the front door I'm just like
oh don't open it my leaves are a great
cliffhanger I'm all shocked they didn't
end like the season that I wasn't a good
cliffhanger there uh and and you got
other interesting stuff going on that
you wouldn't think would go on but few
episodes before the end again you would
think they would save it for the end and
that's the group splitting up um one
more really touching scenes by the way I
think they played a little bit for last
but it's really surprisingly touching is
when the brother and sister deciding
who's
go see the father because one can travel
with a and the other has to stay behind
and originally is going to be katara
because you know the harangue you know
tend to be a little bit of an item but
then she says no you know what Sokka
you're bad for lack of a better term
you're closer to dad or you want to see
him more so why don't you go and he just
for a split sucky gets like this little
teary just go to I got that sister ever
ever and it's they just play it for a
funny little laugh see it's a very again
it's a very genuine heartfelt moment
between siblings I thought that that was
very effective evil was very short so
obviously they they got that going on at
Toth gets captured by the two the two
earthbending people that are going after
her and Azula breaks in with her to her
two friends there and obviously it's
going to turn everything into chaos so
yeah i i'm curious what they're gonna do
this how my episodes are i left like two
yeah two episodes left so i'm curious
what's going to happen this amount of
time that's going to just totally screw
everything over before the beginning of
the next season because that's a lot of
stuff to lay on site you know it is it's
like the red wedding it's like hey
here's the probably one of the biggest
moments but it's gonna come before the
actual end and you know inches leave you
going well now i have to see the last
episode of the last two episodes so uh
yeah just a good episode of good good
and showing too that i think there's
always this thought that the people high
up are always they're always evil no
he's not to be trusted stuff and a lot
of times i think it's more just they
don't know you know so much is kept from
them now of course with today's day and
age uh and technology is just everywhere
information is everywhere so you can get
it but again who's saying this
information and when you are so high up
you have to ask yourself how much do the
people know to and how much do my group
of people know so i
I like that I like they didn't just play
him up as a jerk he was obviously very
naive and not super bright and
unbelievably sheltered obviously but he
was not a jerk and I liked that they
didn't just make him the evil leader or
anything like that I'm also curious if
we're gonna go more into why the
second-in-command was trying to shelter
him and not trying to get involved in
the war I mean they're making it look
like he's in cahoots with the Fire
Nation I'm wondering if I go more into
that
so yeah just man what a good cliffhanger
I mean even though you see a comic it's
just like a bow yet so it's it's a real
good cliffhanger and I enjoyed that
greatly um can't think of so much else
to say about this episode and I like
what Aang said just as soon as we get
Appa back we're gonna split up again you
know we're gonna split everybody up so
I'm curious to see where this goes it'd
be it'd be interesting if there's a
season where just everyone is split and
it has to go that way like maybe two
people on one adventure two people on
another adventure into on another
something like that and that's how it
has to be that'd be interesting and it's
all about trying to find their way to
get back together uh I don't know that's
the route there going to be an
interesting route but yeah I'm
definitely curious to see where the next
one goes because I was that's a really
good cliffhanger so that's it I'll see
you in the next one